people are always asking why the bitcoin
price goes up or down well the short
answer is simply its supply and demand
when you have the supply fixed of an
asset you simply have to look at demand
and obviously price goes up when demand
increases and price goes down when
demand decreases now the more complex
answer is not just simply supply and
demand you have to ask yourself why is
demand going up or down in many cases
bitcoin through the first number of
years was not a financialized asset what
does that mean it simply means that
people retail investors were holding the
asset and they didn't behave the same
way that wall street or institutional
investors behaved but now bitcoin's
beginning to be held by more and more
institutional investors more of those
wall street organizations more of those
capital allocators they have bitcoin on
their balance sheets or in their
investment funds and so when wall street
starts to react to something in the news
whether it's something like interest
rates or a new variant of a virus or
anything else that could spook wall
street or get them excited they treat
bitcoin like many other assets in their
portfolio now bitcoin doesn't have a
completely highly correlated
relationship to other assets yet but it
definitely has become a little bit more
correlated in the beginning years of
2020 and 2021. now what i expect to
continue to happen is more large
financial institutions buy bitcoin is
that bitcoin will become more and more
financialized over time so one is really
important for non-financial
organizations and institutions to hold a
majority of bitcoin we don't want the
banks or billionaires holding bitcoin
and controlling it by simply being able
to say well at any point i can't
actually control the network i don't
control 51 of the mining power but i can
simply sell all of my bitcoin and i can
crash the price the second thing is that
we have to pay attention to a lot of
those macro factors obviously we live in
an environment where inflation is
rampant we have 6.8 cpi and interest
rates are low they're at around zero
percent in the united states well if all
of a sudden the macro factor started to
change and interest rates got raised but
also the inflation number started to
come down you'd have to ask yourself how
many people are still going to flock to
bitcoin i personally don't think that
100 of people are simply adopting this
digital currency because of macro
factors i don't think most of the people
who are going and buying bitcoin or
earning bitcoin or saying to themselves
i'm doing this because inflation's at
6.8 or i'm only doing this because
interest rates are at zero no instead i
think that bitcoin serves as a different
asset for different people it
accomplishes different goals in some
cases people are actually using bitcoin
to protect their purchasing power in
some cases people are using it as a
medium of exchange because it's quicker
or faster they can use things like the
lightning network or layer 2 technology
in order to whip it around the world
instantaneously and completely for free
and in other cases people are simply
using bitcoin as a speculation tool it's
the most risky thing in their opinion
that they have in their portfolio and
they simply want to have a small
exposure to it because of the asymmetry
that it provides regardless of why
people are adopting it it's very clear
that the growth rate of bitcoin
continues from an adoption perspective
at an incredible rate bitcoin has been
growing at 150 to 175 percent annually
compounded for a decade that is
incredible growth for any sort of
technology or financial product now the
big question that we're gonna face is as
bitcoin continues to go up and down you
have to look at what is the relative
relationship of volatility between
bitcoin and other assets right now it's
about 12 move in bitcoin is equivalent
to about 1.7 move in the s p 500 that
means for every 12 that bitcoin goes up
or down that's the equivalent of the s p
going up 1.7 or down 1.7 percent
volatility is the name of a game as it
gets adopted as the world tries to price
what is this worth and right now the
world is saying the strongest computer
network in the world the most
decentralized automated central bank
this decentralized peer-to-peer payment
system it's worth about a trillion
dollars in market cap i personally think
it'll be viewed as much much more
valuable than that over time but
understanding the short-term price
movements is not nearly as important as
having a long-term perspective if you're
a long-term thinker if you're a
long-term investor then the short-term
price movements shouldn't affect
anything you do don't make short-term
investment decisions if you're a
long-term investor that's the key to
letting compounding work so whether you
think that bitcoin is the future or you
think it's simply a speculation tool
ultimately what you have to look at is
these short-term price movements don't
matter over a long period of time pay
attention to what bitcoin's doing pay
attention to its fundamentals pay
attention to the macro environment but
just because you're educated doesn't
mean that you have to act